ooh
i haven't seen my baby how long haven't
seen
all right
i love you
offset just surprised cardi b with some
seriously lavish gifts after being away
for just a few days
oh yes honey on tuesday the up rapper
showed off the over-the-top designer
prezi she received from her hubby on her
insta story and we're talking chanel
people lots and lots of chanel maybe how
long haven't seen
all right eight day nine days
i love you
this is really pretty
yeah snowflake
snow snowflake
well and i just bought a chanel it was
kind of perfect for this
thank you
yeah and the gifting didn't stop there
like not even close
yeah
yeah because yo
i'd be [ __ ] up house sandals so fast
now you already know what's that let me
tell you something when i get
oh
are you so cute when i get house sandals
bro i wear them to death i [ __ ] up house
sandals in literally one week he's like
cute i love this color
yeah the migos rapper didn't just buy
her one pair of sandals he bought her
two because you know a girl's gotta have
options give me fashion and the whole
thing made cardi's day feels so much
better i've been having such a sucky day
of brightening today baby
[Music]
but if you thought the chanel stopped
there
think again yeah
babe
thank you
i love you
[Music]
oh
he's so sweet
i love you
of course when it comes to gift giving
cardi and offset are the reigning champs
i mean who could forget when the grammy
winner gifted her man with a half a
million dollars cash for his birthday
back in 2019. everything you got every
car
you got air jewelry what else can i give
somebody they got everything
the fridge
yeah you heard me
thousand dollars cold hard cash
that's five hundred thousand dollars
five hundred thousand dollars
who needs wrapping paper and ribbon when
you can keep that gift crisp in the
fridge anyway offset loved it
obviously
i don't gotta give you the money but you
know what i'm saying i don't know what
to give you so i suppose i gotta get
excited you could buy a car
you could buy more clothes you could buy
jewelry you could buy me more birkin
bags
you could do whatever the hell you want
then in december the mom of two upped
the ante and gave the migos rapper a two
million dollar check for his milestone
30th birthday
i know you got a lot of business
ventures coming in 2022 so
let's get it
[Applause]
of course let's not forget back in
october offset surprised cardi with a
mansion in the dominican republic
oh snappity snap snap so whether it's a
chanel shopping spree a mansion or a
fridge full of cash no one does a gift
exchange better than cardi b and
offset oh
he's so sweet
i love you
[Music]